I'm gonna say something controversial
and I don't care I don't care how trendy
or cute or fun it seems to be fat
don't let that shift with your head
don't let the idea that oh I could catch
it no matter how big I am cause you to
forget about your health and to keep
gaining weight
I actually feel kind of guilty for being
a part of this movement and I know it's
not my fault or my responsibility to
keep other people's Health but being a
Pioneer in this game like I literally
was one of the first influencers to work
with fashion Nova before they even had a
plus size line so when I say I'm a
Pioneer I'm a Pioneer I'm one of the
main reasons why we have the plus size
fashion industry that we have and you
could argue with anybody that's the
truth and my point is is that I see a
lot of fat girls who gained a lot of
weight from being caught up in this
movement and turning around five six
seven years later talking about damn I
let my health go to [__] I got this
problem now I'm 400 pounds I can't do
this I can't do that babe it's not
always cracked up to be being attractive
being able to still wear nice clothes is
not the end-all be-all you got to really
think about your health because when
you're in your 20s you think that life
is just rainbows and Candy you don't
even think about the future but when you
start creeping up in age babes it's
gonna catch up to you I don't care what
nobody say I'm not saying that every fat
person is unhealthy hello I'm fat I'm
not claiming that you gotta hate fat
people that's literally the opposite of
what I'm saying but let's be [__] for
real health is real organs failing is
real diabetes heart disease all that
[__] is real okay it's not fat phobic to
care about your health and if nobody
else wants to say it let me [__] tell
you the truth love yourself at any size
wear the clothes you want to wear but
don't forget that your heart has to beat
babes don't forget that your blood sugar
has to keep a balance babe no amount of
Instagram pictures looking cute and
being an influencer wearing a size
whatever you are is gonna stop your
heart from not beating if you eating
bacon every day and this is coming from
someone who's learning those [__]
those those those lessons now myself so
to the younger girls the younger
generation take care of your health it's
not fat phobic to take care of your
health it's not a joke and I'm saying
this out of love not out of self-hate I
see a lot of my fellows fellow content
creator fellow plus size fellow bloggers
whatever you want to call them plus size
models now talking about wanting to get
healthy now talking about needing to da
da da because five six seven years ago
when they were 22 when they were 21 25
it wasn't a problem now you're 28 29 30
31 32 whatever the case is and you're
like damn I can't get pregnant I'm
getting I have this problem I got that
problem the problems creep up babe and
the reality is loving yourself also
includes taking care of your body if you
want this body to last 100 years you got
to take care of it so don't let me don't
let nobody else convince you that taking
care of your health is fat phobic and if
somebody's telling you that it's because
they're miserable and they want you to
die and stay fat like them these are
Clips in in reaction to what the other
girl has just said you like to make
videos anymore but I have to say
something about this
um because I have some
own opinion levels as a fat person
myself why are you mad that
there are more fat influencers we grew
up not having any us the people that are
in our 20s grew up not having any
um Tumblr
promote very much Pro animal [__] and um
there are ways we can censor that now
because there are more fat creators that
people can go to to look for I don't
think that y'all really care about other
people's homes because y'all don't talk
about skinny people y'all don't talk
about you know
y'all don't your mindset you don't have
disabled people in your mind you don't
have people that have medical issues you
don't have people that were born that
way my uncle was born Big Bone stop
using disabled people please to Shield
yourself from valid criticism it ain't
because they got a valid reason to be
fed that it makes and I mean that
because even disabled people like we
have to do a lot to maintain it and
fight it okay and they're not big
they're not talking like you don't use
oh they got a thyroid that's not you
stop and the people you're using hate
when you do that too they hate it don't
you only care about disabled people when
they're convenient for your argument the
percentage of people affected with
hyperthyroidism is five percent it's not
all y'all move on so I already left a
comment about this and I wasn't gonna
say anything else because my moods are
already Gathering her
but I got to say something like I I
really tend to sit back and mind my
business I'm not minding my business
because it's people like her that
generally make my ass it's just a 10th
degree y'all only ever want to have
conversations about health and wellness
when it comes to fat people
no that isn't true people have
conversations about health and wellness
when it comes to alcoholics when it
comes to people on substance abuse
people talk about health and wellness on
a whole different variety of stuff they
talk about it in a sexual context when
people are out there doing things
frivolously that's why there's so much
sexual awareness we talk about health so
[__] often it's crazy
and I'm grateful I think it's good we
need to be more conscious especially
when there's so much bad [__] that we
can eat there's so many bad habits we
can easily fall into when so many things
are easily accessible we're talking
about banning cigarettes in places
health is a common discussion in our
site guys because people are becoming
much more health conscious today than
they have ever been I grew up in a time
where people used to be smoking indoors
how do you think that changed people
started voicing health concerns it
became a big topic of conversations and
then there was a bunch of laws that
ended up being passed because they felt
like it was an issue
and let's say because said for a lot of
different habits health is often
discussed so I reject the notion that we
don't talk about it that is not true
what do you want no
no all right sorry let me say that one
more time y'all only ever want to have
conversations about health and wellness
when it comes to fat people you are not
addressing food deserts
y'all not talking about how unaffordable
Health Care is you're not bringing up
the fact that people with diabetes have
to ration their insulin because they
can't afford it do you know how
expensive asthma inhalers are
like do you understand that people don't
have access to basic resources what is
this deflection I remember people
talking about Healthcare not being
accessible for a long time it has
nothing to do with you people with all
kinds of disabilities different issues
health problems having to go to avoid
the hospital because you don't want to
pay a big medical bill like this has
been a topic how do you think Obamacare
even came about or some of the
subsequent bills that came afterwards
this idea that people don't talk about
the Health Care system and how things
are unaffordable is totally not true
this is not true
this comes down to the same thing that I
was saying earlier was like it almost
looks like every fat person who like
does this kind of stuff online has the
same talking points and they repeat it
verbena you bring up that there's a
Health crisis and that
people got to make better choices and
they start rattling off things where
they can deflect and not have to talk
about the issue but that's exactly what
something that is trigger does they
don't honestly answer the question or
they don't really whenever I'm gonna do
a video talking about whatever the
person is like a reaction but she's not
responding to whatever anything she that
she said the other person said that's
the most
I don't care how many of her car you
want to sit here and be like oh yeah she
was just she just cares about how people
she just want people to be careful I
don't care oh you have an opinion and a
preconceived notion about what health is
I've not moved no mountains are moving
over here we don't have to move you
'll be very difficult but we don't have
to oh we're not even gonna try no no no
I don't care I don't care we don't gotta
move you you gonna hit your 40s and
you're gonna be moved by the doctor
you're gonna be moved by a health
diagnosis you're gonna be moved by your
shortness of breath You're Gonna Be
Moved when you struggle to take a [__]
you're gonna be moved when you struggle
to get out of cars you're gonna be
moving and you're gonna be moved when
you can't move because your knees are
[__] up we don't got to do nothing you
will see the dark future that comes for
you because guess what honey nobody gets
to be your way and gets to be very old
in life they don't vast majority of them
are dying
I don't have sympathy I start to lose it
after a time when I realize that you are
out here hurting other people with this
rhetoric you lose me because I've seen
too many people I care about I have to
die
people that were amazing contributors in
society died because they didn't have
any more limbs to cut off after diabetes
their heart just gave out life is going
to do two things either move you or
remove you
bars that is a bar that is a bar that is
a bar say that [__] again life is going
to do two things either move you or
remove you yup and I've been moved
trust me yep
thought this one was really interesting
because like her main rebuttal was just
immediately drawing a bunch of like
false equivalencies to try and make her
point when really they have nothing to
do with anything like yes all of those
things are very valid things to talk
about in the medical system very valid
concerns but just because all of those
things exist does not mean we shouldn't
talk about other things that exist thank
you shout out to you homegirl who's this
Megan Ann shout outs to you Megan Megan
Anne are you really gonna sit here and
tell me oh These people aren't as big as
you think they are when because when I
look at this photo um what I'm not
saying that you have to look like the
two women on the left but there is
something clearly wrong with the woman
on the right not saying that she's not
worthy and deserving of love because she
is but she's unhealthy she can hardly
fit in her freaking shoes I am so
confused why on Earth would we promote
people walking around and looking like
this it's not healthy and it's honestly
mean to say that someone is beautiful
and all this stuff when it's like we're
literally lying to them and making them
think that it's okay to be that way when
it's really not because it's hurting
their health and it's shortening their
lives if you really care care about
people you tell them the truth I just
saw the video that everyone in body
positive Tick Tock is talking about and
I want to make a very quick point that
anyone who talks about fatness being
trendy or a trend or cool don't listen
to them they're not credible anyone who
says that is honestly delusional because
look at how fat phobic and diet Centric
and just demonized fat people and
fatness is in society he was saying it's
a trend who is saying it's trendy
it's demonized everywhere what's to look
forward to what's cool about it what's
trendy getting harassed on every single
platform you can be both you can be
trendy and demonized
I'm glad people are demonized but hella
trendy
it's been trendy on Tick Tock people are
stealing the dances and doing that and
everything in the third stealing the
music and all that
trendy demonized
you can be both
so the fact that some bad thing is that
you could be life is not one
etiquette one tag
people can be many things at the same
time and sometimes those things
are the opposite true I'll give you good
sometimes not long ago
Kim Kardashian was talking about the
beauty standards and she was saying oh
the beauty standards is so it's so
excessive and it's hard to keep up and
this and that and I went
[__]
you're the beauty standard true you are
the reason why
people are like that people look like
you but
this thing can become bigger than you
and you have to keep up with it hence
making you also a victim of what you
created yeah Kim K got a patent on bbls
every time you get a BBL
one dollar goes to her legal fund that
she uses it against Kanye
it's funny
but that's funny but but that but that's
pretty much it so yeah the fact that you
could be one of the yeah it's possible
so you speak to your example we demonize
pills and illegal substances all the
time guess what there's also other
subsets of our culture that encourage it
remember lean and music
there's ways in which even though
something can be demonized in certain
sub-sectors and other ones we can be
encouraging and pushing it to people and
making it cool and accessible hence what
he's talking about right there even
though in general society looks down on
this whole being fan being obese
absolutely there's other
subsequents of the internet in different
places which encourages it which makes
it acceptable or almost
enables people to continue doing so when
they are out here saying like you can
eat anything there are no bad foods if
you want to eat Oreos go ahead and this
thing's stupid and that's a nutritionist
paid for by food companies that's them
creating messaging to get to you
and it's not even individuals and just
influencers companies are literally
paying millions of dollars in marketing
money to get certain kinds of messaging
out there to make their terrible Foods
more appealing to you this is not even
just an individual thing there are
systemic problems that encourage a lot
of this stuff but there's absolutely
culturally issues that enable your
behavior I don't think being fat is
trendy but I do think it honestly has
become more socially acceptable over
time I'm not saying that's a bad thing
either because representation is very
important I think we also have to be
honest uh and also just absolutely not
surprising not like a fat acceptance
Creator would just diminish someone
else's experience right away without
really listening to what they're trying
to say I feel like that happens often
somebody who is part of the whole fat
acceptance thing uh and a pioneer of it
realized some of the things that are
wrong with it and now she's being
accused of being a grifter a sellout uh
engaging in fat phobia for telling
people to be health conscious to really
start to take it into consideration
and now it got so bad she ended up
deleting her video and pretty much going
offline for a little bit because she was
being harassed by so many of these
people from the fat acceptance movement
listen
it's either life moves you
or it removes you
do things so do what you got to do yep
yeah that's pretty much it
that's what you guys think